[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est l'heure
de par le break dobrogea katia bonjour
michael moore faire l'actualité
politique et parlementaire grande
actualité cette semaine avec vous et
avec notre invité au rang d'art g
bonjourbonjour député de la 10e
circonscription des yvelines est l'une
des porte-parole du groupe
elle rêve à l'assemblée on va revoir
avec vous le film politique et
parlementaire de la semaine l'examen des
projets de loi pour la confiance dans la
vie publique qui a été achevé après 17
heures de débats en commission et
quelques cafouillages
on reviendra sur la conférence des
territoires sénat emmanuel macron a
tenté de rassurer des élus inquiets et
puis semaine marquée par la démission du
chef d'état major des armées sur fond de
contestation du budget emmanuel macron
est venu à istres pour tenter de
rassurer les militaires et on commence
donc avec la loi de moralisation à
l'assemblée nationale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les députés auraient écrit plusieurs
dispositions qui avait été adopté par
les sénateurs ont notamment voté la
disparition de la réserve parlementaire
et le principe des notes de frais qui
crée quand même quelques polémiques rami
cas et maïté vraiment vous résume tout
ce projet de loi
17 heures de débat dans une ambiance
tendue
en témoigne cette scène où la présidente
de la commission des lois fustige
l'attitude de son groupe face à
l'opposition
l'un des points de crispation majeur de
ce texte le remplacement des frais de
mandat par des justificatifs une mesure
impensable pour certains députés avec le
contrôle de savoir si vous avez déjeuné
avec talent industriel avec tel
responsable politique etc etc et donc
et pourquoi avoir déjeuné dans un hôtel
3 étoiles et non pas dans un mcdo vous
est contée mc do qu'est ce que ça veut
dire
donc à partir du moment où vous ne
présentez pas que des factures de mcdo
toutes les banques facturent vont être
rejetés
ça ça demande un certain nombre de
dépenses qui sont d'une variété infinie
c'est le plein qu'on fait
[Musique]
le panier de la ménagère qu'on remplit
parce que ils ont pu de quoi donner
donner à manger aux enfants pour la
soirée c'est véritablement une
foultitude de choses pour lesquelles on
peut pas avoir deux justificatifs
consensus toutefois sur la suppression
des emplois familiaux par les élus mais
l'amendement proposé par le rapporteur
du texte sur la définition de la famille
est jugée trop floue par l'opposition
parmi d'autres mesures controversées la
suppression de la réserve parlementaire
difficile à défendre
il ya certainement d'autres - ma manière
de faire dans une politique que nous
voulons plus éthiques
nous pensons que c'est une pratique qui
ne peut plus fonctionner en toute
transparence donc supprimons la scène
non non elle n'est pas transparente et
elle est finalement adopté quant aux
verrous de bercy il a été réinstaurée
malgré sa suppression par le sénat et le
casier judiciaire vierge a été adopté
ces deux projets de loi sur la confiance
dans l'action publique seront discutés
dans l'hémicycle dès lundi 24 juillet
j'aimerais parler du fond dans un
instant que vous avez entendu début du
reportage vous avez un groupe qui dort
c'est vrai écoutez moi j'ai vu surtout
une président de la commission qu'il a
en l'occurrence rapporteur qui était
extrêmement active sur ce groupe et
naïma mucho notamment qui est la
responsable du groupe nous en commission
qui a été présente à tous les instants
on s'est beaucoup réunit aussi en groupe
c'est à dire et à la fois les gens de la
commission des lois qui sont réunis puis
ça a été élargie aussi à toutes celles
et ceux qui avaient envie de contribuer
sur ce texte par exemple je suis passé
en commission des lois mais on a
contribué on a proposé des amendements
dont certains qui ont été pris en
commission des lois dont je pense que
voilà on doit avoir une collégialité sur
ce texte qui est essentiel vous
répondent pas vraiment à ma question
mais moi je moi écouter j'ai vu un
groupe qui était actif qui était présent
à la fois en commission des lois en
réunion de groupe est soudé c'est ça qui
compte parce que le chien au final c'est
le texte qui sort de la commission des
lois qui est important ce texte me
semble cohérent
n'anticipait des soi-disant recul vous
voyez qu'il n'y sont pas bien au
contraire et ça a pu créer de la
polémique plutôt avec l'opposition qui
aurait aimé qu'on aille moins loin et
c'est ça que je retiens c'est ce que le
texte va dire et c'est ça qui est
essentiel à mon avis justement on a
senti certains députés être plutôt
réticent sur la réserve parlementaire
etc
pour vous il faut en finir avec ces
pratiques ça fait partie du passé qu'est
ce que vous pensez de cette attitude ce
qu'ils sont dans leur rôle les députés
quand ils font de la résistance comme ça
en disant ça va être impossible à
justifier les factures etc
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
attitude moi je pense que ce projet de
loi il pose deux questions la première
c'est qu'elle est l'utilisation que l'on
fait de l'argent public puisque ça n'est
pas notre argent que nous gérons mais
l'argent public que ce soit sur
l'indemnité des frais de mandat que ceux
sur les enveloppes des collaborateurs
que ce soit sur la réserve parlementaire
par exemple et ensuite est-ce que les
décisions que l'on prend elles sont
motivées par des décisions et des
jugements politiques ou est-ce qu'on est
soumis à des intérêts particuliers et
c'est la prévention des conflits
d'intérêts c'est ça mon avis les deux
questions essentielles qu'on doit se
poser donc oui sur la réserve
parlementaire c'est un instrument
politique il faut pas se cacher la face
là dessus c'était un instrument
politique qui permettait d'avoir une
influence d'avoir un poids politique
dans sa circonscription
oui ça a pu aider décider des
associations et des collectivités
locales
sauf que pour moi ça n'est pas aux
parlementaires de décider seul de
manière discrétionnaire qui est éligible
et qu'ils aient faim assure qu'elle
pouvait quand même cette réserve
écoutez moi je pense que c'est une bonne
chose qu'elle soit supprimée à nous en
tant que parlementaire d'accompagner les
associations d'accompagner les
collectivités locales dans la recherche
que ça va changer beaucoup de chance
pour mais à nous de les accompagner dans
la recherche de subventions par exemple
à nous les accompagnant le montage de
projets ça on peut le faire mais est ce
que c'est un député seuls de décider de
l'utilisation ou non de 150000 euros par
an de dire quelle association est
éligible ou non alors oui elle la liste
des associations vous soutenez lé public
mais sur quels critères vous avez fondé
votre jugement y aura forcément est
toujours une suspicion qui pourraient
exister moi sur ma circonscription j'ai
cinquante et une commune
comment je fais l'arbitrage entre
différentes communes qui peuvent avoir
des problématiques identiques
jean priori une sur l'autre mais sur
quels critères objectifs tout 20
forcément ma décision elle sera soumise
terreau gadhia aussi la question des
notes de frais que les députés devront
désormais produire et il y aura dès lors
en tout cas c'est le dispositif actuel
mans qui est prévu des contrôles
possibles ça sera très difficile de
contrôler chaque facture chaque
déplacement
c'est possible il ya un dispositif qui
sera mis en place pour permettre ce
contrat lors les modalités seront
confiées au bureau de l'assemblée et du
sénat donc soit il y aura une avance qui
sera réalisé parce que par exemple sur
les défauts faut bien comprendre les
choses l'indemnité de repro natif de
frais de mandat
ça n'est pas un complément de salaire ça
n'est pas un salaire supplémentaire
c'est une indemnité qui doit permettre
de mieux payer vos collaborateurs pascal
enveloppe collaborateurs ne suffit pas
toujours de louer une permanence est
d'avoir des frais pas donc c'est un
vecteur des choses précises et ce à doha
elle m'a déjà il va y avoir une liste
précise qui va justement dire quelles
sont les dépenses éligibles et celles
qui ne le sont bas et ensuite sur les
modalités est-ce que ça va être une
avancée est ce que ça va être un
remboursement
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on devra
justifier des dépenses que l'on fera et
c'est assez normal enfin moi je viens du
privé c'est toujours quand j'ai engagé
des frais du justifié l'homme normal
justement qu'est ce que vous pensez vous
de la progression qu'a formulé manuel
valls il aimerait peut-être que s'il y
avait une revalorisation salariale pour
les parlementaires notamment pour les
députés est ce que ce pour vous c'est
quelque chose qui est possible ce que ça
peut choquer l'opinion
non moi ce que je retiens l'intervention
de manuel valls en commission des lois
parce que j'étais présente à ce moment
là c'est qu'à mon âge il pose une vraie
question
pas juste sur la question du salaire il
pose une vraie question qui est quel est
le rôle du député et cette question là
il va falloir qu'on y réponde
est ce qu'on considère qu'un député
internet chutait de la nation ou est-ce
qu'on a un député de notre
circonscription a battu les raiders du
statut aux et déjà c'est politiquement
comment on articule ou non les
conventions et justement aujourd'hui on
n'a pas encore été au bout de ce
raisonnement là je pense qu'on va y
venir avec la loi constitutionnelle du
soin de projets de la conscience parce
qu'à partir du moment où on réduit le
nombre de parlementaires où on introduit
une dose de proportionnelle
forcément ça va changer aussi la nature
du rôle du député on a aussi dit qu'on
voulait rénover le travail parlementaire
en disant par exemple qu'en début de
mandat on allait voter la loi mais qu'on
allait surtout avoir un
on leur en force et d'évaluation de côté
trop là et ça ça change la nature du
travail parlementaire sur la question du
salaire pour moi elle est honnêtement
pour moi honnêtement elle est
anecdotique je considère qu'on gagne
suffisamment bien notre vie et que l'on
ne trouve d'autre avait plus d agir en
europe qui gagne encore encore mieux
kiki aux wanna qu'ils gagnent moins un
acte le gagnant plus tout ce qu'il faut
c'est qu'il ya un salaire en effet qui
correspondent à la fois je pense au
temps que l'on y consacre et qui nous
permettent justement de bien de bien en
vivre sans que cela se paraissent
démesurée aux yeux des français il faut
pas tomber dans un excès à l'autre il se
dire il faut doubler notre indemnité ni
comme monsieur rufin qui lui j'ai
beaucoup de ses droits d'auteur dire
qu'il faut tout d'un coup est payé au
smic
il faut éviter le populisme à mon avis
d'un côté celle de l'autre alors robert
g cette semaine un invité pas comme les
autres est venu au palais du luxembourg
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le président de la république en
personne est venu au sénat pour
inaugurer la conférence des territoires
objectif rassurer des élus locaux qui
sont inquiets des réformes qui est des
attentes notamment en matière de
fiscalité locale flora sauvage opération
séduction pour emmanuel macron lors de
la première conférence des territoires
qui s'est tenue aujourd'hui au sénat le
chef de l'état a tenté de faire avaler
la pilule aux élus locaux les
collectivités locales devront réduire
leurs dépenses de 13 milliards d'euros
d'ici à 2020 des associations dans son
discours préalable
j'ai un larcher a tenu à mettre les
points sur les i pour pouvoir mener des
politiques publiques ambitieuses
les élus communaux départementaux et
régionaux ont besoin d'avoir un cadre
d'action clair et stable des ressources
prévisibles
cela suppose une vraie culture de
concertation la conduite d'études
d'impact préalable solide
or nous n'en avons jamais à ce discours
musclé le chef de l'état maintient le
cap
c'est un pacte de responsabilité
partagée des manuels mâcon propose aux
élus locaux
je crois profondément que dans la très
grande majorité des cas les territoires
en réalité savent mieux l'organisation
qui est la plus pertinente pour eux il
faut donc construire ce pacte girondins
que j'ai évoqué il ya quelques semaines
qui sans briser l'unité nationale au
donnera aux territoires les moyens
d'agir nous est donné plus de liberté
aux collectivités locales un droit à
l'expérimentation où la reprise en main
par l'état du financement du rsa autant
d'annonce accueilli favorablement mais
sur la question des finances le compte
n'y est pas nous affirmons notre
position plus que réticente c'est une
opposition à la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation
au terme de cette première conférence
des territoires si des élus locaux salue
la méthode les propositions financières
passent mal il reste des points de
friction cas de la réforme de la taxe
d'habitation est la question centrale
des dotations si sur ce point le chef de
l'état n'a pas rassuré différents mais
les dotations c'est une question
centrale est dans la constitution des
choses sont claires quand on enlève des
ressources aux collectivités locales
pour les compenser est-ce que vous
pensez que
les élus ont de quoi être rassuré alors
même qu'on n'a pas eu toutes les
précisions de comment est ce que je vais
attendre la taxe d'habitation c'est
extrêmement clair c'est à dire que ce
qu'on a annoncé l'air pendant la
campagne présidentielle se vérifie
aujourd'hui avec les propos du président
de la république il y aura une
exonération de la taxe d'habitation pour
80 % de français qui sera compensée
c'est un dégrèvement donc ça veut dire
que c'est qu'on pense que l'état savait
que les mots ne sont pas les mêmes et
les sénateurs jeudi une compensation au
général ça va la première année jamais
la deuxième c'est pour ça que vous
mettez en place notamment la conférence
des territoires qui était un engagement
du candidat emmanuel macron tous les six
mois qui est un comité d'évaluation qui
sera mis en place pour évaluer de
manière régulière tous les six mois
également le coût de la réforme est en
effet qu'à l'euro près les communes ne
pâtissent pas de la suppression de 80 %
des français la taxe d'habitation parce
que le volume de population plus âgée
qui devrait leur fille dans sa sécurité
sociale que c'est en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est qu'il ya deux les deux
engagements et son conjoint à la fois le
fait que 80% des français d'ici la fin
du quinquennat ne paieront plus la taxe
d'habitation parce que c'est un impôt
qui est socialement et territorialement
injuste pour les français et que les
communes à la fois gardent leur
autonomie fiscale à dire là le choix
dans la fixation de leurs taux
6 à 16 ans en fait ce qui est certain
c'est que par contre elles seront
compensées sur la base du taux au moment
de l'entrée en vigueur de la loi ce
temps il y aurait un effet d'aubaine qu
on imagine assez bien et il n'y aura pas
de manque à gagner pour les concurrents
un dispositif durable qui va permettre
de compenser cette perte d'une ressource
importante pour les collectivités c'est
sûrement une opposition assez ferme à
toutes ces propositions est pas étonnant
qu il n'est pas étonnant la paroisse
françois baroin qui est constructif mais
il est en campagne il me semble pour
redevenir le président l'association des
maires de france c'est pour ça qu'il est
sur ce long mais je pense que déjà il
était pendant la campagne présidentielle
puisque s'il faut sauf si on avait gagné
lors était premier ministre
donc qu'il était sur ses positions la
wii mais il a toujours été en tant que
président l'association des maires de
france moi je me souviens du candidat
emmanuel macron qui était allé devant
l'association des maires de france qui
avait achevé des positions qu'ils
n'étaient pas les plus faciles à assumer
devant les maires mais qui les avait
assumé en campagne électorale
alors qu'en général les femmes
agricultrices il faut et il réaffirme
des engagements de combien de mois je
pense que c'est aussi sa kangoo
il faut tenir ses orangers engagements
de campagne quand la vie au sénat il
parle du nombre des élus locaux qu'il
faudrait diminuer
ça c'était pas prévu ça ben on avait
toujours parlé nous à la fois d'une
réduction de nombre de parlementaires ce
qui sera prévu dans la loi
constitutionnelle et aussi d'une
rénovation en général de la vie
démocratique
les mêmes qui critiquent aujourd'hui
étaient les premiers à soutenir la
réforme à l'époque de nicolas sarkozy du
conseiller territorial qui faisait que
vous aviez une fusion des conseillers
départementaux et régionaux avec
clairement une diminution du nombre
d'élus si à mon avis est une bonne chose
c'est d'inciter à la fois une
clarification des compétences une
réduction du nombre des élus
aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas des
compétences qui sont clarifiées on a
toujours la clause de compétence
générale pour les collectivités qui fait
que toute collectivité alors
d'intervenir sur tout le champ de
compétences qu'elles le souhaitent
ce qui n'aide pas à mon avis à la
clarification est un enchevêtrement et
que cela peut prêter si vous avez eu des
échos sur votre circonscription de
toutes ces propositions qui ont été
formulées
moi je sais pas d'où consommation
notamment les plus petites communes
moine et élus des villes il ya
exactement il ya cinquante et une
commune mois dans la m on en a parlé il
ya à la fois des maires qui sont pas
très heureux de la manière dont les
choses se sont passées sur les
communautés d'agglomération parce qu'ils
ont l'impression d'avoir subi des
mariages forcés
en fait de s'être allié sans avoir de
projet territoire réel d'avoir eu
l'obligation de le faire dans un temps
extrêmement court sans réfléchir
vraiment sur les compétences qui étaient
liés à ces nouvelles entités et puis des
communes qui réfléchit sociale et fusion
entre elles pour aller plus loin dans la
mutualisation mais aussi parce qu'ils
ont du mal à trouver des
à renouveler leurs conseils municipaux
on l'avait vu en 2014 les plus petites
de nos communes c'était compliqué de
trouver suffisamment de candidats et
donc l'idée aussi d'une fusion
c'est la mutualisation des services des
dunes pas boucle kunming positif
en tout cas moi je n'ai pas eu j'ai pas
été appelé en rafale par des mères en
disant attention là on est en train de
faire une grave erreur
je pense qu'au contraire ça a plutôt une
logique de clarification
on va revenir sur une autre polémique de
la semaine avec un début de crise entre
le président de la république et les
armées après la démission fracassante du
chef d'état-major des armées emmanuel
macron s'est rendu sur la base aérienne
d'istres auprès des forces de dissuasion
nucléaire opération reconquête
céline martel opération séduction pour
emmanuel macron en visite sur la base
aérienne d'istres
le chef de l'état prend le temps d'aller
à la rencontre des soldats dans son
discours il multiplie les hommages aux
militaires et salue la carrière du
général pierre de villiers
l'ancien chef d'état major des armées 24
heures après sa démission le général de
villiers a souhaité hier passer la main
c'est son choix et je le respecte
entièrement je tiens à lui rendre un
chaleureux hommage car il a été un grand
soldat aimé et admiré de ses subordonnés
et il vous a brillamment commandé
pendant un peu plus de trois ans
pierre de villiers protestaient contre
les 850 millions d'euros d'économies
réclamer aux armées cette année emmanuel
macron tente de rassurer les troupes
je veux que vous ayez les moyens de la
mission d'assurer et d'exécuter la
stratégie définie
je ne laisserai personne dire que tel ou
tel choix budgétaires se fait aux dépens
des forces de votre quotidien de votre
sécurité
c'est faux le chef de l'état réaffirme
que le budget de la défense sera portée
à 34,2 milliards d'euros en 2018
il précise qu aucun autre budget ne sera
augmenté cette année là son objectif de
porter l'effort de défense à 2% du pib
est lui aussi maintenu
revenons sur cet épisode donc de
démission d'un chef d'état major
il a démissionné c'est une première en
même temps on a le sentiment de propos
un peu dur et notamment il ya cette
information au lit ce matin par le
figaro qui relaie des propos de
christophe castaner qui dit ceci le chef
d'état major a été déloyale dans ça
comme il a mis en scène sa démission
et il évoque un poète revendicatif est
ce que ce n'est pas allé un peu trop
loin que de dire ça mais moi je pense
que il faut passer à autre chose
surtout on a un nouveau chef
d'état-major repos 2 on a un nouveau
chef d'état major des armées qui a été
nommé en conseil des ministres dès
mercredi on a un ancien chef d'état
major des armées qui a signifié un
désaccord je pense que je pense qu'on
peut regretter le fait que 1,8 clos et
été brisées vous le savez rien ça ça
crée un précédent qui est très grasse
que parce qu'on se sert d'une commission
parlementaire au sein de tous
oui je trouve que c'est un précédent qui
est grave parce que dans une commission
parlementaire soit celle de la défense
et les affaires étrangères rien huit
clos l'idée n'est pas de le briser
parce que sinon celles et ceux qui
viennent ne se sentiront pas en
confiance ou ne diront plus rien ça
c'est un point à mon avis importe celui
qui erre de m je sais pas qui c'est je
vais pas faire une chasse aux sorcières
mais je trouve que c'est ce que sebbah
admissibles je pense que c'est en tant
que parlementaire nous n'avons pas à
divulguer ce qui se passe dans le huis
clos d'une enceinte qui est là pour
respecter la parole de celles et ceux
qui viennent après de fait il ya un
désaccord public qui a été signifié
qu'il a été accélérée par le relaxer
propos exactement mais de fait le
désaccord est devenue publique et je
pense que je lance un chef d'état major
des armées a acté en fait ce désaccord
et en a tiré les conséquences en
présentant sa dette estimé que toute
cette séquence qui a duré une semaine a
été bien traité par le président de la
république
en tout cas elle a été vite traité c'est
à dire que vous avez tout de suite un
nouveau chef d'état major des armées qui
a été nommé l'ancien a démissionné le
mercredi matin
elle est nommée concède logés dans des
des arcanes des affaires quelle
peut-être il ne voulait pas rentrer fort
mais le chef de l'état et chef des
armées
tout simplement et peut-être que les
gens jusque là même découvert président
non mais j'ai jamais appelé jupiter est
faux je pense qu'il faut arrêter avec
avec ce type de symboles qui sont je
trouve éloigné mois de de la vision m
qui est celle du chef de l'état on l'a
on l'a vu encore cette semaine quand il
est venu dans les mains oui enfin il ne
s'est pas comparé à jean terre voilà il
ya des excès de langage qui à mon avis
voilà où on a envie de démontrer que ce
serait une présidence qui serait soit
disant trop autoritaire trouve sous
titres en fait on re découvre juste
cette semaine que le chef de l'état est
aussi le chef des armées que c'est lui
qui fixe la stratégie qui est celle de
la france en matière aussi de défense
est tout simplement on a eu un désaccord
qui a été rendue publique on peut
regretter encore une fois la méthode qui
fait que ça a été rendu public malgré le
huis clos au sein de la commission mais
a été rendu public et on a un nouveau
chef des gardiens est donc un président
de la république qui vient voir les
forces en se mettant en tenue donc de
marins ou deux pilotes comme bien ça
c'est normal c'est pas juste une
opération de com je sais pas ça me
paraît tout aussi une marque de respect
vis-à-vis de celles et ceux qu'il
rencontre je pense que c'est important
vous a pas échappé que le jour même où
il a été investi président de la
république il a souhaité se rendre sans
aucune caméra au chevet justement à des
militaires qui étaient blessés
un père s'est rendu également au mali
s'est rendu hier à istres donc
clairement l'armée elle et elle a un
rôle essentiel
son budget va augmenter comme il n'aura
jamais augmenté avec 34,2 milliards
d'euros
c'est une entrave et surtout avec la
nouvelle loi de programmation militaire
qui sera étudiée qui sera valable de
2019 et 2024 fait que dès 2025 le budget
de l'armée sera bien porter comment
s'est engagé à 2% du pib
ça veut dire 50 milliards dont ont
visité en quelque sorte
aujourd'hui il faut tourner la page de
cette séquence son propre état oui je
pense qu'il faut passer à autre chose en
effet mais je pense que c'est le cas de
fait on a un nouveau chef d'état major
des armées
on a un budget polémique et on a un
budget de l'armée qui va être en
augmentation qui est le seul garçon
l'avion et il faut monde et fait avancer
alors c'est l'heure des clients d'autres
partenaires du figaro matile siro et
amis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour ma fille bonjour michael bonjour
katia bonjour aurore bergé
un jour on va revenir un petit peu sur
le fonctionnement du groupe
lrm à l'assemblée nationale lundi soir
vous étiez à l'hôtel de clermont la
résidence du ministre des relations avec
le parlement christophe castaner vous
étiez avec les députés et la république
en marche mais aussi avec emmanuel
macron puisqu'il a effectué une visite
surprise il a assuré qu'il n'y aurait
pas de caporalisme dans le groupe
est-ce qu'il était nécessaire cette mise
au point non moi j'ai pas du tout vécu
une mise au point lundi par le président
de la république mais moi j'ai vu des
parlementaires qui était très heureux de
le revoir dans un contexte un peu
différent que celui du congrès à
versailles comme vous l'imaginez et moi
je retiens des mots du président de la
république ce qu'il a dit qui nous avait
déjà dit d'ailleurs lors du séminaire
qu'on avait au moment de notre campagne
législative qui était de dire nous ne
serons jamais des habitués dsi ou des
repus et finalement si à une mise en
garde c'est plutôt de nous dire qu'on
était là pour être au travail et qu'il
fallait pas oublier pourquoi on avait
été élu le par qui et par qui on avait
été une réaction
mais grâce à qui peut-être n'ont cessé
pas c'est pas ça c'est une a parlé des
français il n'a pas parlé de lui
à aucun moment il a juste exprimé le
fait qu'en en effet on est des jeunes
parlementaires pour beaucoup d'entre
nous et on sait pourquoi on est élu on
sait qu'il ya une urgence à agir une
urgence obtenir des résultats il a
relevé marc donnera pas la même et
retrouver ce qui se passe dans ce groupe
à l'assemblée nationale c'est pas du
tout l'impression que vous avez vous
pensé qu'il vient contrôler action à
l'assemblée nationale parce qu'il vient
passer une heure avec les parlementaires
de notre groupe franchement interroger
les parlementaires du groupe demandez
leur comment ils ont ressenti la
présence du président de la république
je pense qu'au contraire ils étaient
heureux de pouvoir le revoir dans un
autre contexte qui était un peu plus
informelle que ce qu'on a pu connaître
ces derniers temps lors des visites ou
des placements qui sont évidemment
officielle et qui ont des cadres et des
formalités un peu différente il moi
vraiment ce que je retiens de son
intervention c'est n'oubliez pas
pourquoi nous sommes là et ce qui nous a
dit c'est les français ont pris un
risque
avec ce renouvellement avec ce renouveau
il ne nous pardonneront rien il
pardonneront encore moins qu'à ceux qui
nous ont précédés donc on a vraiment une
obligation totale de réflexion on a
parlé des cafouillages un petit peu de
la confusion parfois qui règne au sein
du groupe s'est remarqué par certains
députés de votre groupe mais aussi par
ceux de l'opposition est ce qu'il n'ya
pas un risque que ça vous desservent
dans l'opinion
vous pouvez être référence à quoi par
exemple à la phrase de la présidente de
la commission des lois qui a parlé d'un
groupe voterait d'un groupe qui dort
c'est quand même important c'est quand
même des déclarations qui sont pas très
très positif pour votre couple
moi j'ai déjà répondu à cette question
il me semble qu'on a un groupe qui était
extrêmement présents en commission des
lois
on a beaucoup critiqué la présidente de
la commission des lois parce que j'ai
entendu dire christian jacob qui fallait
forcément avoir trois mandats de
parlementaire pour être prises en
commission n'ont pas forcément est
d'ailleurs en général ceux qui avaient
trois mandats de parlementaires n'ont
pas été reconduits par les français lors
de cette élection législative parce que
justement il y avait une profonde envie
de renouvellement et de renouveau et je
pense qu'il ya le bruit mais elle permet
aussi ça elle a une compétence en la
matière elle a été élue choisi par notre
groupe pour elle de présenter la cause
juste une petite question en passant on
dit d'eux ayant des déformations un peu
accéléré à la procédure parlementaire
elles ont eu lieu et c'est qu'elles sont
desservies par l'assemblée nationale oui
oui mais elles ont eu lieu et enfin
c'est pas facile pour certains de
présider les séances on voit alors ils
sont jeunes ils sont où elles ont eu
lieu ça se passe comment on a eu des
formations qui ont été présentés par
l'assemblée nationale à l'ensemble des
parlementaires n'a pas eu de formation
spécifique mais peut-être qu'il y en
aura d'autres
en tout cas qui seront mises en place
par l'assemblée je pense que c'est utile
vous savez la technique parlementaire ça
s'acquiert
on vient tous de quelque part on a tous
développé des compétences
professionnelles dont on a parlé aux
erreurs avaient cafouillage en tête mais
c'est vous qui voyez du cafouillage moi
ce que je vois c'est qu'au final il ya
eu 17 heures de débat dans la commission
des lois
on a un texte qui va être débattu en
séance publique dès le lundi 24 juillet
et je pense qu'il va dans le bon sens on
a un texte qui sort de la commission des
lois qui est cohérent regardons plutôt
le fond du texte encore une forme
on peut dire un mot sur richard ferrand
le président de votre groupe est ce que
vous estimez qui tient à c le groupe et
quel regard vous portez sur ses débuts
je sais pas s'il faut tenir le groupe
c'est cette expression que je conduis
d'un président mais géré je ne sais pas
si en prison l'armée un président de
groupe est là pour tenir un groupe
président du groupe il est là pour faire
vivre le débat au sein du groupe il a
pour permettre l'expression des
parlementaires est là pour permettre la
mise en oeuvre qu'on est dans la
majorité du projet sur lequel on a été
élu il me semble que c'est ça qu'on a
mis en place on a fauté la probable
prolongation de l'état d'urgence
on a permis le vote des lois
d'habilitation sur la question du
travail avec un certain nombre d'heures
de débat qu'on disait qu'on allait
confisquer le débat il me semble qu'au
contraire l'opposition a pu largement
s'exprimer et nos parlementaires aussi
et vous l'avez relevé souvent aussi sur
ce plateau de parlementaires qui étaient
d'anciens chefs d'entreprise notamment
qui ont pris la parole et qui ont montré
l'expérience qui était la leur et ça va
être la même chose sur le projet de loi
sur la confiance
une toute dernière question sur le
fonctionnement de l'assemblée nationale
les députés hommes ne sont plus obligés
de siéger avec une veste ou avec une
cravate est ce que c'est une victoire
pour les insoumis est ce que c'est un
progrès selon moi d'istres perçage pour
ça que ce soit un progrès après ça n'est
que mon point de vue personnel parce que
je pense que on doit respecter les
institutions dans lesquelles on siège
tout simplement et je pense pas qu'être
enfin la modernité passe pas forcément
par ce genre de choses la modernité
s'est rénové le travail parlementaire
souhaite qu'ils aient moins de navettes
parlementaires cette demande de voter en
commission un texte définitif ça ça me
paraît de plus en portant sur la
rénovation et travail parlementaire que
de savoir si on doit porter une cravate
ou et bien merci merci matile merci
merci d'avoir été notre invité de la
dernière de la saison
au début on se retrouve la saison
prochaine
ciao
[Musique]